[Applause]
hey everybody yeah that's my name
Alec state you can find me on the
Internet at eighty underscore fresh
underscore death I'm from Toronto Canada
any Canadians here a few of us yes and I
work at a front-end consultancy they're
called wrangle and we're having a little
hometown love right now the Toronto
Raptors made it into the NBA Finals and
won their first game so lots to be proud
of but we're also proud of our very
first Canadian competitor in RuPaul's
Drag Race yeah so Brooklyn Heights made
it to the finals which happened last
night no spoilers a little bit about me
I am a front-end web developer and this
is my family since people are showing
families today I have a human baby and a
fur baby Avery and Trixie but we're not
here to talk about that we're here to
talk about functional CSS and all of the
feelings surrounding it so what is
functional CSS just to get a lay of the
land who here has worked with functional
CSS okay that's like maybe 10% cool so
you all are gonna benefit from this talk
essentially it's just a CSS paradigm
it's so it's a way to handle your
classes so the classes themselves should
be small global reusable single purpose
and immutable which I'll put in quotes
because it's not that you can't change
them but the idea is that you don't and
the class names themselves should
indicate their visual or structural
purpose so you can think of them like
Lego blocks each class does one thing
and one thing only and the class name
describes what it's doing so with Lego
you might have like agree
in two by six you wouldn't say this
greenpeace is part of the wing of my
helicopter and just some sample classes
an example will be w 100 so that would
be a width of 100% flex display flex BG
black background color black so each one
is only doing one discrete piece and
what that looks like in your markup is
kind of long strings of classes that you
compose together to build your UI so in
case you can't see the this div has W
100 which means with 100 W 50 M which is
a media query so honest on a medium
sized screen it's gonna be 50% with W 33
L that's gonna be 33% width on a large
screen flex would be display flex item
center would be a line item center BG
black will be background black and PL 3
would be a padding left 3 so you kind of
compose all these things together to
create the UI and let's talk briefly
about the name functional CSS like where
did this come from and how is it
relevant so functional has many
definitions but there's a couple that
are sort of useful for functional CSS
the first is ever having a special
activity purpose or task relating to the
way in which something works or operates
so it's how something works so what's
its purpose and a second is designed to
be practical and useful rather than
attractive and you'll see you know from
the markup I just showed and from some
of the complaints people have your
markup isn't pretty but functional CSS
isn't designed to make your markup
beautiful it's designed to be useful and
practical and what's a function we're
all web developers here and there's lots
of things that a function can be but
with respect to math and code it's
essentially a situation where you have
an input and an output and something
happens in between and you want to be
able to predict your output based on
your input
so what puts the function in functional
CSS rather than the classes being
functions I like to think of the markup
itself as being a function so the idea
is you're you're inputting these classes
and you can predict what the rendered
output is going to be so if you think of
the markup is the thing you're inputting
into and then whatever's rendered on the
screen as the output and any functional
programming fans so for those who love
functional programming in JavaScript
there's a lot of familiarity so we have
the concepts of immutability so with our
functional classes we want to declare
them once globally and not change them
single purpose so much like a functional
programming function it should be doing
one thing so the classes do one thing
they're reusable so you declare them on
a global level and then you use them
throughout your code base and they're
composed so when you're doing functional
programming you're you're composing
functions and with functional classes
you're composing them together and there
shouldn't be any side effects so with
functional CSS you shouldn't be having
to predict what the Cascade will do or
some specificity weirdness because
things are global and immutable
you shouldn't have unperturbed
unpredictable outputs so just to make
sure we're on the same page about what
functional CSS isn't for today's talk
I'm not referring to CSS component
libraries or frameworks meaning things
like bootstrap or angular material where
there's full-on components given to you
those libraries often do leverage
functional CSS as a part of what they
offer but I'm just talking about the
classes themselves as discrete CSS
classes not full-on components in since
the word functional is in there I just
want to be sure everyone knows we're not
talking about CSS and j/s today love it
but that's not our subject
so people have a lot of feelings about
functional CSS
there's the lovers and the haters and I
want to look at both sides of the
argument today so let's talk about what
people don't like so the HTML can be
ugly you can have these long strings of
classes in line in your markup people
really don't like that and there's a lot
of comparisons made to inline Styles but
I want to make sure everybody
understands the differences so with
inline Styles you can write literally
anything and it will take precedence
it'll it'll override things whereas with
functional classes usually if you're
working from a library you're going with
a system so you're not just writing
anything willy-nilly you're pulling from
a discrete set of values that have
already been defined for you so there's
a lot of structure involved inline
Styles don't support media queries most
functional CSS paradigms do inline
Styles don't support hover or focus
States functional CSS does and inline
Styles can only target one element at a
time so you're directly writing it on
the element whereas with functional
Styles your your you can use these
classes on multiple elements another
critique is the separation of concerns
so there's a lot of thought out there
about how styles and context are in
content need to be separated so your
HTML shouldn't be concerned with your
Styles that's kind of where semantics
class names come in the idea is that if
you're if you're describing the style in
your class name that's that's this
coupling things that's coupling your
design thinking with your structural
thinking yeah so essentially they they
don't want markup to be concerned with
style
but there's kind of this dependency
direction thing that happens where
either your markup is depending on your
Styles or your CSS Styles or depending
on your markup because when you have
semantic class names that might say
something like
and a whole bunch of styles that's then
tied to the structure in the in HTML
versus having HTML with class names like
Flex where you're you're tying things to
the design so it's a dependency
Direction choice you don't really ever
have this separation of concerns and
it's kind of a myth and there's a great
article written by Adam Lawson who is
one of the creators of tailwind and he
debunks this really well and is really
worth reading but this quote kind of
sums it up my markup wasn't concerned
with my styling decisions but my CSS was
very concerned with my markup structure
so another critique is that it's not dry
do not repeat yourself for those who
don't know the dry acronym so yeah you
are gonna be reusing strings of similar
classes like there's patterns that
you're going to use over and over again
and that is a critique of functional CSS
however where you gain is that you're
cutting down dramatically on the number
of times that you're writing the same
CSS rules like drastically cutting that
down so you might be a little more like
wet in your in your markup but you're
going to be extremely dry in your CSS so
that's kind of a false critique again
it's it's choosing where do you want to
be dry and then just the general concept
of semantics class names people really
really like semantic class names to
describe the structure and you know like
with sass you can get into nesting
things and and really paralleling your
your markup structure and just to make
sure we're all on the same page this is
an example of a semantic class name
where I have a container around some
drag queens it's called the queen
container and I've got some properties
on it and it's really tied to the
structure of my document so in this case
with semantics class names you're
describing what it is not how it works
or how it looks whereas a functional CSS
you're very much describing how it
functions and how it looks
and I want to talk about the word
semantics semantics means to give
meaning so when you have a semantic
class name you're describing the content
the structure of the HTML and that's the
meaning but when you have functional
class names like flex or red being the
color red there's still meaning it's not
that it's unsymmetric it just has a
different meaning and when we think
about the purpose of classes really
their function is to be a hook for a
JavaScript or for styles the job of a
class in in my opinion or in the opinion
of many isn't isn't to describe the
structure of your document because
that's already done in your markup so
making it describe your structure that's
that jobs already been taken care of by
the structure itself so what problems
does functional CSS try to solve as
Rachel mentioned this morning CSS has
lots of problems we all have dealt with
frustrations we all love it too or it
wouldn't be here but I think there's
kind of four main problems that
functional CSS tries to address probably
the biggest is performance and CSS bloat
so there's the actual performance aspect
when you cut down the amount of CSS that
you're writing you're delivering a
smaller bundle it's pretty straight up
but there's also the the like dev time
bloat where you don't have to be writing
the CSS so unlike a selfish level it's
kind of nice to just know how these
classes work and be able to put them
together and not have to spend a whole
lot of time writing CSS on the
performance level Adam Morris who's the
creator of tachyons which I'll be
talking about a little bit today
he wrote this great article called CSS
and scalability highly recommend as well
and he looked at a lot of large websites
this is a couple of years old so I don't
know how current the statistics are but
Pinterest for example has more than one
megabyte of uncompressed CSS spread out
over five files 97% of it isn't used on
the home page
I'd rather just try and send my users
the 3% they do need so there's this
thing where a lot of websites and and
applications have to load all of the CSS
in order to view a single page whereas
they don't necessarily have to load all
of the HTML to view a single page so
having a little bit of bloat in your
HTML is is probably still a lot cheaper
than having a lot of CSS and just to
show in Adams article he clicks to some
gist where he shows repeated properties
so from Pinterest he looked at where
they wrote display:none over and over
and over again and this is just a small
screenshot but it's actually two hundred
and sorry six hundred and twenty-six
lines of code and it's just just for
display:none perp interest so if they
had leveraged a functional class of
display:none they would have written it
one time so scalability is definitely a
thing when you are writing custom CSS
all the time you probably aren't going
to memorize every single class that you
wrote anywhere and look for ways to
reuse it and you're probably not gonna
search your entire code base for
everything you could possibly reuse
which means that scaling out a codebase
means you're just writing a lot of CSS
you're you're having to continually grow
the stylesheet and that means that not
only is it harder to scale as a
developer but your user then has to
download all that extra CSS another
thing that can happen there when you're
writing a lot of custom CSS is
especially on shared code bases like
probably a lot of us work on enterprise
level applications with multiple
developers collaborating on git and then
you get into inconsistent values and
patterns functional CSS one of the main
selling points is that there are systems
that you follow and you agree upon you
don't necessarily have to buy into the
system of a library you can create your
own or you can customize a library but
either way you're you're sort of
agreeing on a on a standard set of what
is allowed in your codebase
and then yeah so decoupling styles and
structure CSS that's tightly coupled to
markup isn't easily reusable if you have
say you have a component and you've got
your queen container for example and
you're describing everything it's really
hard to reuse that somewhere else like
you have to put a lot of effort into
abstract things it's not impossible you
absolutely can but functional CSS makes
it really easy to decouple these things
[Applause]
so going back to Adam Morse and Lego
when I used to build things with Legos
I never thought oh this is a piece for
an engine block I thought oh cool this
is a 1x4 blew Lego and I can do anything
I want with it and that is really the
the key concept here and then this one
from like a selfish developer time
perspective you're minimizing context
switching so when you get really
comfortable with functional styles you
can just write them directly in your
markup and you can really predict how
it's going to turn out
you might occasionally want to refresh
your browser and take a look at things
but you're not constantly toggling
between a CSS file and a markup
structure it's just really fast to kind
of put things together once you get
comfortable and know how the pieces work
and similarly when you're in the browser
you can just be writing some Styles
inline in your in your markup and you
don't even have to get into the CSS dev
tools if you're using functional Styles
one more at Morse code that that article
is so good so it's CSS and scalability
in a great system there's a two-way
street of information if you look at the
CSS you can tell what will happen if you
look at the HTML you know what the code
will do so the idea is here that if you
look at the the functional styles that
have been defined you know what each one
does a class of red is going to be color
red there's no questions there and then
when you look at your markup like I know
when I see something that has pa4 that's
padding all four I know what you know in
a Tachyon situation for works out to I
think it's one Ram or something and I
just get you see
things and I can predict what they look
like yeah I'm not here to sell tachyons
like I don't work for tachyons but I do
work with tachyons and I find it to be a
really great library to play with and
and it does work for me in production I
would recommend checking out their docks
because they're really really helpful
everything is kind of visually shown Oh
everything shows you examples of how to
write it in the markup what each class
does there's visual layout examples the
docks are really great so one of the
things that's awesome about tachyons is
it very much as a scale based system so
there's a font scale a type scale
padding scale margin scale everything
kind of breaks down into sort of design
system scale thinking so let's check it
out we've seen elephants and dogs and
stuff but I'm going to show you drag
queens so I made this app it's some of
my finest work really like super proud
of this so this is just a grid of images
you can resize it it's responsive really
it's just beautiful yeah so I built this
first using sort of a more traditional
approach so this is not a react app it's
not an angular app it's not
componentized at all it's just
straight-up HTML and CSS just to
illustrate the point here so you can see
here in the markup I've got the cream
container around things there's a
heading with a div around it there's
individual images for each queen and
then in them in the CSS everything is is
written out in sort of the more
traditional style with semantic class
names and towards the bottom we've got
some media queries to handle the
responsiveness of the layout and here
we're going to redo it with tachyons
so first thing we're gonna do is bring
in the CDN I would recommend importing
the library if you're gonna do it in
production but just to play with the CDN
is great we're killing our old markup
and bringing in tachyons markup so you
can see we've got some familiar classes
now flex with 100 there's some media
queries on the images with 50 on medium
and then this is the fun part
CSS how gone all of it delete all the
things and then just you know I'm being
honest I renamed the title to drag
royalty 2.0 and then we'll give it a hot
refresh in the browser and this is the
same site and it's still responsive and
the layout is exactly the same with zero
CSS not zero CSS functional CSS so yeah
what do the lovers have to say like I
just showed you I don't have to write
any CSS this is a false dream this is
not the situation you are gonna have to
write CSS and I think if your motivation
to get into functional CSS is that you
don't want to learn CSS that's going to
lead to problems and pain in my
experience on projects where a where I
do use functional CSS I'd say 50% of my
components I'm still writing some
components go up CSS and there's still
some global CSS that I'm writing to
affect the whole code base so it's not
like a Silver Bullet only solution but
it's it's cutting down dramatically on
the amount that I have to write and then
the bundle size - because tachyons
itself is only 15k so yeah the bundle is
so small there's an article you can find
that's called 15k of CSS is all you'll
ever need and that's a good one but I
also think that that's not really the
situation in my experience yes you can
save a lot of bundle size by using
tachyons but you are gonna have to write
your own CSS there's gonna be a good a
good amount of it
this is very true I can work so fast
once I got used to functional CSS which
realistically took me two or three weeks
like it wasn't a steep lean learning
curve I just find that I'm I'm I'm
writing it really fast and I'm
prototyping in the browser super fast
it's just made our workflow really
really smooth reuse all the things this
is very much true so you're reusing this
global stylesheet that you've either
created yourself or pulled in from a
library and then you can take this one
step further by component izing your
system where you know each component has
a string of classes but you're not
duplicating that everywhere you're just
reusing that component so you're not
necessarily having to rewrite the same
strings of classes constantly and this
one is super super awesome I can think
in design systems so you know having
worked closely with designers who are
also familiar with with functional CSS
I'm able to sit down with them and be
like okay how do you you know how do we
want to customize the scale do we like
the scale cool now that we're on board
the scale how do we want to use it and
you know somebody can just ping me on
slack and be like I need that to be
actually like margin level five instead
of margin level four and it's just like
the easiest communication flow because
you're already thinking in the same
system and of course that's possible
with other systems is this is just one
that works well so so what do I do in
production on a code base is where we
are using functional CSS which you know
is client specific I do work at a
consultancy so I have different
different clients with different comfort
levels with this type of stuff but when
I do I use the functional classes as
much as possible and it reach for those
first before I try to write my own CSS
which in the beginning requires
searching the docs a lot and getting
comfortable but eventually you really
just know what's up and then you
customize the library is needed you
don't have to take it out of the box I
I'm sure to componentize as much as
possible so that I'm not having to
rewrite the same things over and over
again both with the markup and the CS
and then when I have to I'll component
scope classes so if I don't think
something is reusable but it is a
specific situation where I need to be
just doing something outside of tachyons
I'll components go bit first before I
reach for the global scope and then when
you do want to get into things that are
reusable through your code base but
don't come from the library of course
you're going to need some global CSS for
that in those situations if I'm going to
write utility classes that might be
reused everywhere I try to remember to
prefix them
so in this app I might call it like DQ
flex 12 or whatever like drag queen so
you're like pre fixing things just to be
sure that there's no weird interaction
with the functional library in case
there's a random class you're not aware
of prefixing is just a nice way to
prevent that so just a few cautions
learn CSS I don't think I have to preach
to the choir here but as I said if you
think this is a shortcut to not learn
CSS you'll feel the pain as soon as you
have to write your own and you don't
understand what's happening
so definitely learn CSS and use this as
a tool within your your palette of
things you can do a CSS this one I've
seen don't import the full library to
extend a class from it so there was a
component that I was working on for a
component library so it was a drop-down
that was going to be used all over
multiple products for a company and
someone had imported the entire library
of tachyons just to extend a class like
margin top two so tachyons is 15k that
means every list item in every drop-down
on every product has 15k of CSS on it so
just just don't do that if you feel like
you want to be extending things maybe
it's a good time to be writing your own
CSS component scoped and this one's
really big CSS or functional CSS is
super exciting and it's really fun to
play with but don't be the developer who
goes home and then rewrite
an entire collaborative code base
without buy-in from your team if you're
interested in bringing it into your
project and I will say I've used in
production a lot and it's great make
sure your team is on board it's a huge
code style change and you don't want to
be doing that stuff and being
heavy-handed and just kind of demanding
a new way what I'd really recommend is
that you go home and try it out on some
little silly side project make some drag
queens or whatever and then show your
colleagues and and see if they're
interested because yeah that can be
really disruptive to a team vibe to just
dogmatically make a decision and yeah do
you this is not a silver bullet it's
only one possible way of handling your
CSS there's lots of cases where I still
write custom CSS and I'm very grateful
that I know it and love it try it out
don't push it on people if your team
isn't ready be chill but yeah if you
don't like it you don't have to like it
like nobody has to do anything it's just
a cool thing to check out
I want to thank CSS comfy you for having
me today and everybody here for
listening and I want to thank all of the
people who've written great articles
about functional CSS because I read
about 30 of them in preparation for this
talk there's lots of great stuff you can
find online by just googling the subject
feel free to hit me up on Twitter and
I'll be sharing my slides later today
Thanks
[Music]